قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه من
الواضح ان الاداره في السويد التي سمحت
بحرق المصحف امام السفاره التركيه في
ستوكهولم لا تنتظر دعم تركيا في عضويتها
في حلف الناتو على حد وصفه جاء هذا خلال
مؤتمر صحفي عقده اردوغان عقبه رؤوسه
اجتماع النقل حكوماته في انقره
الامن والشرطه وتباهما فعل ذلك باستهدافه
للمسلمين لذا فانه من الواضح انه لن ينتظر
من سمح لهذا الفعل المخزي ان يحدث امام
سفارتنا ان نقدم له الدعمه بخصوص موضوع
طلبهم لعضويه
لاداره السويد ان تحدثنا عن الحقوق
والحريات اذا كنتم تحترمون الحقوق
والحريات في هذه الدرجه فعليكم اولا ان
تحترموا المعتقد الدينيه للجمهوريه
التركيه وللمسلمين اولا
ده نتيجه الحكومه الالمانيه حرقه نسخه من
المصحف الشريف خلال احتجاجا قرب سفاره
التركيه بالعاصمه السويديه
ووصفته بانه استفزاز يهدف الى اثاره
الانقسامه وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الالمانيه كريستيانر ان اوروبا
تؤيد التعايش السلمي بين كل الاديان
كان فعلا
المجتمع السويدي
الاستفزازات من هذا النوع تهدف الى اثاره
الانقسامات ويجب ان يواجهها بكل تضامن
وتماسك تماما مثل حوريه التظاهر وحريه
التعبير فان حق الانسان في حريه الدين
والمعتقد هو احد الاصول القيمه التي تعمل
الحكومه في دلاليه وشركائها الاوروبيون
على الترويج لها في جميع انحاء العالم
وخطاب الكراهيه بدوره ليس جزءا من القيم
الاوروبيه تؤيد اوروبا تعيش السلمي بين
جميع المناطق السويد وتركيا كلاهما عدوان
في مجلس اوروبا مع الاتفاقيات السلام